le coup de coeur du cinéma les yeux
d'elsa cette semaine ça n'est ni un ni
deux ni trois ni quatre films mais si
film nous participons cette année comme
depuis quatre ans au festival play it
again c'est un festival qui a pour but
de mettre en valeur les films du
patrimoine qui sont nombreux à sortir
sur les écrans français
tous les ans on a choisi donc 6 cette
année deux films français le trou de
jacques becker et qu'elle dure face de
clouzot un film
pour les grands enfants et puis ceux qui
ont des souvenirs de ce film qui a été
un grand succès billy elliot de stephen
daldry des charlots et puis deux films
américains importants les moissons du
ciel de terrence malick le premier
chef-d'oeuvre de terrence malick mais
surtout mon petit chouchou
le lauréat de mike nichols qui a fait
découvrir au monde entier le talent de
dustin hoffman alors le lauréat c'est
cette histoire d'un jeune homme qui
vient de finir ses études et puis qui va
entrer dans une relation avec une femme
d'âge mûr est jouée par anne bancroft
évidemment tout se complique quand tout
à coup son père lui demande de sortir
aussi avec la fille de cette dame ces
dames c'est 1006 robinson tout le monde
connaît cette chanson de simon and
garfunkel toute la bo a été fait par
simon and garfunkel et voilà c'est un
très très beau film qui a permis à mike
nichols d'obtenir l'oscar du meilleur
réalisateur en 1968 qui sort maintenant
donc pour son 50e anniversaire et que
j'aurai le plaisir de vous présenter le
20 avril en séance unique à 20h30 lors
d' une ciné-conférence je vous attends
donc au cinéma les cieux de l'esa pour
le festival play it again